If you have not already done so,
please download the linear
example data Excel file.
Microsoft Excel and Google Sheets
are not able to easily handle categories
with linear aggression, so we're going
to use a more sophisticated software
program called Alteryx for this example
and much of the future courses.
There's a brief overview
of Alteryx below the video.
Note, there are techniques
that you can use to leverage
spreadsheets to handle categories
with linear regression, but
we won't review these
techniques in this course.
First let's open up Alteryx.
Now drag an input data tool from
the tool bar onto the canvas.
Click on the drop down arrow
in the configuration panel and
select File Browse.
Navigate to where you saved the linear
example data Excel file, and select it.
And then select Open.
Since the data is coming
from an Excel document,
a window will pop up asking you to
choose the sheet that you want to read.
In this case there's only
one sheet labeled Data.
Select Data and
then click the OK button.
Note, if you have the document open in
Excel, you'll get an error in Alteryx
saying that the document is
already in use by another process.
You'll need to close the document in
Excel before you open it in Alteryx.
If you click on the input tool, you'll
see the configuration in that window on
the left side of the screen along
with the preview of the data.
Now that we have the data selected
to be brought into Alteryx,
we can grab a linear regression tool
from the predictive tools category and
drag it into the canvas next
to the input data tool.
In the configuration panel,
we can set up a linear regression.
Working our way down the configuration
steps, let's name our model.
I'm going to name mine ExampleReg.
Now select the drop down that is
labeled select the target variable.
This will list all the variables that
could be the target variable for
the linear regression
in alphabetical order.
Remember that a linear regression has
to have a numeric target variable, so
only number fields will be
displayed in this list.
Select the column called
Average Number of Tickets,
because this is the variable
we're looking to predict.
In the next box, which is labelled
select the predictor variables,
there are a list of variables
that could be used as predictor
variables in the analysis,
with a check box next to each of them.
To include a variable as a predictor
variable in the analysis,
simply select the check
box next to the variable.
Select the variable's number of
employees, value of contract, and
industry.
There are two additional check
boxes in the tool configuration.
We're not going to check these options.
For more information see
the section below the video for
additional materials.
Now that the model is set up,
let's add a browse tool to the r
output of the linear regression tool.
Right-click on the linear
regression tool and select,
add browse after reports.
This will produce a report that we can
read and assess how good the model is.
[BLANK_AUDIO]